I just think they're running out of
ideas it's getting a little lame here
are some BuzzFeed lists I saw recently
check this one out seventeen clouds that
look like Drake odd one look at this one
six panties that literally melted when
Tom Hardy walked by Oh gross yeah look
this 14 cutest head puppies who support
a Muslim ban no puppy no puppies just I
don't know I love him but I'm sorry I
can't agree with them look at this look
at this choose three racial slurs and
will correctly estimate the height of
your fridge I mean how does it work I
don't know I'm not right Luis twelve
beautiful outdoor picnics about to be
ruined by a demon overlord five times we
made joe scarborough's head 30% larger
what's the same to me much the same
check this one out eight iphone screen
cracks that resemble Jesus check this
out nine guys who have no idea they're
on tinder take a number between one and
ten and we'll pick a number between 11
and 20 what kind of list is that check
this one out 32 staunchly pro-gun
activists who are currently bleeding to
death now
hey I didn't like this one check it out
you won't believe what the cast of the
honeymooners looks like now thank you
thank you I cut that one over her soul
and people were like I think we should
keep it in I mean it's it's been a while
yeah no I was wrong and thank you nine
spot what do they take the time to throw
you out of the bus I don't know it was
really Jeff Rosalyn said keeping it I
know our producer Jeff Ross was the one
that said keep it in that's the guy on
the left if you're a high he's the guy
he's the guy that always says I cut it I
wouldn't do it get defensive I wouldn't
do it I wouldn't do it and then today he
sees that one and I'm like we should
take that and he's like I think we
should do it I think we should do it
they're all dead let's get him they're
dead they're dead let's get him they're
dead that's what he said oh man if only
I had some power here at Conan all right
check this next one out nine spiders
that are about to get sued for that
copyright image in there whoa
you go hey we're all friends again
yeah we're all friends again just in
time for this one and finally 14 strands
of anal beads your aunt Carol thought
were
Erol
you